After a loss, do you ever feel...
invisible?
No
mostly because people are always
extremely mean to me
I was like yo
I’ll never grab that ring
but my God
have you seen my STATS?
Whoa, pros only
Remember...
the Titans?
Oh yeah…that’s right, the Titans
I forgot about them
We lost to the Bills
and nobody knows we exist
Yeah, we should be household names
right Corey Davis?
Correct, Derrick Henry
We need a makeover for the
Gridiron Heights homecoming dance
I heard you’re looking for a culture change
Well, I used to play linebacker
WHOAAAA. SO RELATABLE.
First, we’re gonna touch you guys up
with some underperforming Patriots
Next, we’ll give you a whole new look
Wow! Two-tone gray sleeves!
Lastly…
it’s all in the attitude
Here
We go for it on 4th down now
So we’re basically the same team-
-That fired our coach after winning a playoff game
-And made slight roster changes
We’re beautiful!
Where are the Titans?
I need them to beat me one more time this year
Hi…
Look at those unis
Whoa
that’s a true big-market team
if I’ve ever seen one
Wow, the Rams got hot over the summer